mériadec raffray journaliste spécialiste
défense bonsoir monsieur merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors pourquoi ce changement de position
si on peut appeler ça clairement un
changement de position aujourd'hui
bonsoir stéphanie je pense je parlais
pas d'un changement de position je
parlerai de ballons d'essai des skis ce
d'une ouverture d'une alternative
stratégique à celle qui après existe
jusqu'à présent au sel tout simplement
parce qu'aujourd'hui
depuis pour faire simple et schématique
depuis le mois d'août dernier le
changement de présidence à la tête de
l'état malien
la france est un peu au pied du mur en
matière de stratégie politique dans la
bande saharo-sahélienne d'ailleurs c'est
assez paradoxal puisque nous sommes à
peu près sept ans après le début de son
intervention dans la zone et on sent que
l'équation de barkan commence à
véritablement porté ses fruits il ya eu
un certain nombre de deux commandes
ajustements qui ont été réalisés et qui
aujourd'hui portent leurs fruits les les
victoires tactiques sur le terrain
s'enchaînent avec de lourdes pertes pour
pour les katiba islamistes mais mais
vous m'avez perdu non non vous et vous
êtes toujours avec nous un cher mais
quand vous entends d'accord bon alors
moi je vous dois plus ça y est je vous
retrouve ses bons dans l'obscurité mais
on est en haut en temps et on vous
distingue donc tout va bien
bon je disais donc c'est paradoxal
puisqu'il ya du côté cessé ses victoires
militaires qui s'enchaînent sur le
terrain avec des bilans qu'on avait
chaînes observées jusqu'à présent des
sorties des opérations de lieu à
plusieurs dizaines de neutralisation de
djihadistes d'un seul coup et de l'autre
côté politiquement parier rattrapé par
par une stratégie qui on le voit bien ne
fonctionne pas depuis le début françois
hollande en 2013 avait dit nous avons
reconquis le nord-mali et maintenant
c'est aux maliens de
andres en main leur destinée c'est en
plus tard on voit bien que ces maliens
là n'ont pas fait le job en quelque
sorte et les maliens eux mêmes
d'ailleurs ne sont pas contents
puisqu'ils ont fini par renverser le
pouvoir actuel avec une une coalition
enfin une action militaire mais porté
par une opposition politique forte qui
en avaient assez en fait de ce surplace
et ce sont ces militaires maliens qui
ont accéléré en fait la possibilité le
scénario de la négociation avec les
islamistes
mettant paris defacto devant le fait
accompli avec un véritable danger c'est
à dire de négocier en fonction de leurs
propres paramètres voire même avec les
hommes qui sont sur la liste rouge des
militaires français je veux parler
évidemment des leaders historiques et
aujourd'hui des leaders djihadistes
estampillé comme tel qui soit d'al qaïda
ou d'ailleurs de l'hygiène ça change pas
grand chose de cette rébellion donc
voilà voilà qu'elle est l'équation
actuelle pour paris et on voit bien que
paris cherche aujourd'hui comprend qu'il
va falloir prendre des décisions et
cherche la bonne alternative
alors à quoi doit-on s'attendre en
termes de résultats toute la difficulté
pour paris aujourd'hui c'est d'une part
de ne pas être pris à contre à revers
par par les maliens
je vous rappelle que lors de la
négociation pour la libération de sophie
petrona il ya quelques semaines la
dernière otages françaises dans la zone
les maliens ont libéré deux sens j'ai à
dist pour faire plaisir à iad agali le
fameux leader du nord islamo touareg
donc ça c'est véritablement un camouflé
et un problème pour les pour les hommes
de barkan donc paris cherche évidemment
à éviter cette répétition cette
répétition qui dirait problématique
d'une part d'autre part paris sait très
bien que qu' il est plus facile de enfin
quand on a commencé une guerre il faut
savoir la terminer et pour la terminer
il faut parler il faut négocier le
général lecointe l'a dit d'ailleurs il
ya quelques quelques semaines dans une
interview à rfi il a dit que
le dialogue actuel esquisse de dialogue
la possibilité de dialoguer avec
l'ennemi est eu un choix politique
il a dit qu'il n'était pas question de
négocier avec des ennemis terroristes
mais qu'on pouvait évidemment négocier
avec un ennemi un an et demi n'ont pas
été en reste un détour pour les
conditions de la pêche nous rappelle
d'ailleurs que d'ailleurs d'ailleurs cet
épisode alors pourquoi maintenant et le
l'elysée lancer des ballons d'essai
parce qu'il va y avoir un prochain
sommet france g5 sahel à la suite des
deux premiers qui sont tenus à pau en
janvier dernier puis à nouakchott en
juin
donc il va y avoir une nouvelle une
nouvelle commande iej entrevue au sommet
entre les partenaires qui font la guerre
aux sels et que par ailleurs cette
opération militaire commence à tard 17
ans je les dis elle coûte aujourd'hui à
peu près un milliard d'euros au budget
de la france que chaque année ce qui est
un coût énorme compte tenu de nos
finances et de notre aide et de notre
budget est par ailleurs il n'est enfin
je pense que paris s'inquiète aussi d'un
certain nombre de commandes hirèche de
problème d'image dans la société
française jusqu'à présent cette
opération a été bien plutôt bien perçue
par les français
mais la lassitude le temps s'installant
et puis évidemment on parle aujourd'hui
par exemple vous le savez que les laits
enfin un rapport de l'onudc dont on ne
connaît pas encore laisse entendre que
les maliens en fait pour être accusée
d'exactions lors des mes combats voilà
ça donne de polémique pourrait naître et
je pense que paris est très attentive à
ne pas se laisser entraîner sur ce
terrain là voilà aujourd'hui quelle est
la situation est évidemment toute la
question de savoir avec qui on va
négocier ça c'est un véritable problème
on ne pourra pas semble pas négocier
avec les leaders il faudra trouver les
sous chefs en quelque sorte
ceux qui ne sont pas mouillés avec les
djihadistes et ceux qui sont en même
temps légitime et représentatifs
c'est à dire qu'ils sont en capacité de
d'imposer sur le terrain un accord je
vous rappelle que il y en avait un qui a
été signé qui s'appelle les accords
d'alger en 2015 et qui sont tombées en
désuétude
marie dit qu'il faut les remettre
en vigueur tout simplement parce que les
gens qui avaient négocié n'était pas
forcément qui avait signé ces accords
n'étaient pas forcément les plus
représentatifs merci d'avoir été raflés
mériadeck pardon excusez moi d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste défense merci à vous